ها هو،
دعونا نتوقف لحظة ونشاهد،
ها هو دونالد ترامب
أول رئيس سابق على الإطلاق
يأتي إلى
أي مكان
ليواجه يومًا في المحكمة، أعتقد أن ما كان
ملحوظًا هناك وسنراه على الأرجح
عدة مرات أخرى  عدة مرات
قبل أن يلقي خطابه ليلة الغد
ولكننا كنا نتحدث في الواقع
من قبل عما إذا كنا سنرى
الضرب بقبضة اليد وما إذا كنا سنرى إبهامنا لأعلى
ولم نر أيًا من ذلك، سامحيني يا سارة،
أريد فقط أن أتحدث
إليك بشأن ذلك لأنه  لقد أمضيت عدة
ساعات وآلاف الساعات في
تغطيته منذ عام 2015. ماذا يخبرك ذلك
بلغة الجسد؟ أعني أنني أعتقد أنها كانت
أكثر استسلامًا بكثير مما توقعناه
مرة أخرى، فلديه الكثير من الفرص للظهور
متحديًا في وقت لاحق اليوم وغدًا عندما  لقد
أخبرك بتصريحات مساء الغد
في مار ألاغو لكنك تعلم أنها
نوع من المسيرة المستسلمة إلى حد ما أسفل
الدرج في سيارته، لا توجد قبعة ترامب، كما تعلم أننا
معتادون على رؤية نوع من
غنيمة حملته بالإضافة إلى  اختيال
وهذا لا يستحق المشاهدة الآن